Elemental witchcraft is the use of earth
wind fire water all centered around the
fifth element which is Spirit this is
the basic building blocks of magic so
listen to what these real life Wiccan
witches and how they teach about the use
of magic my name is be I have been a
practicing hedgewitch for 12 years so
when you call Circle you address each
one of the elements um in their various
directions and you ask them to join you
in your Sacred Space so pay attention to
the way that she talks about calling a
circle addressing the elements and
inviting them into your Sacred Space
that's going to be important when we
look at Frozen and how Elsa calls Circle
the basic introduction to Witchcraft is
learning how to work with these elements
I am going to be talking about some like
beginner Concepts some with craft 101 um
today we are going to be focusing on the
five elements of Witchcraft and calling
circle with them earth air fire water
and spirit and we use all five of these
within witchcraft to uh create Magic hi
my name is Benta I'm the Norris witch so
the elements that witches worked with
nowadays are water earth air and fire so
in my opinion the elements are a very
basic thing that you should learn early
on when you're getting into witchcraft
there's given a book called Elemental
witchcraft that witches promote for you
to learn how to work with magic I'm
excited to finally share my review of
Elemental witchcraft turning the wheel
through Elemental witchcraft so you go
through each of the elements you have
earth air fire water and you also have
spirit so the Bible is very clear on us
having nothing to do with talking with
Spirits or engaging in magic and sorcery
but yet that's exactly what they're
teaching in some of these kids programs
which brings us to Frozen 2 the very
theme of this movie is Elsa learning and
finding the four elements and looking
for The Fifth Element you know air fire
water and Earth yes but look there's a
fifth spirit said to be a bridge between
us and the magic of nature a fifth
Spirit some say they heard it call out
the day the forest fell my father heard
it do you think that's who's calling me
she's basically telling you that the
kingdom fell because of the
communication with these spirits and
messing with magic yet Elsa feels like
it's not bad I woke the magical Spirits
at the Enchanted Forest wait the
Enchanted Forest the one father warned
us about yes why would you do that
because of the voice I know it sounds
crazy but I believe whoever is calling
me is good how can you say that look at
our kingdom I know it's just that my
magic can feel it I can feel it all
throughout Frozen she's literally
looking for these Spirits hey guys need
the wind
spirit we only trust nature when Nature
speaks we listen Fire Spirit get back
everyone to the
[Music]
river Earth Giants
what if I can settle them like I did the
Wind and Fire remember the goal is to
find the voice find the truth and get us
home here is Elsa addressing all four of
these elements which is the basic
building blocks of Witchcraft there fire
water Earth there's even necromancy in
the storyline in Frozen 2 when Elsa is
thought to be dead and she hears her
grandfather speak listen to what he says
understand grandfather we bring
arendelle's full guard but they have
given us no reason not to trust them the
north alra follow magic which means we
can never trust them grandfather magic
makes people feel too powerful too
entitled it makes them think they can
defy the will of a king that is not what
magic does that's just your fear fear is
what can't be trusted in this story line
you have a father that's telling you if
you mess with magic it will produce a
confidence in you to even defy the will
of a king do you want your child to
learn those kind of Concepts thinking
about them spiritually when Elsa decides
that she really wants to see this spirit
being that is supposedly calling her or
talking to her she sings this really
interesting song are you the way who's
the way the Bible talks about Jesus as
being the way the truth and the life to
open
your this is witchcraft
101 she's literally calling the elements
in their directions into her space so
when you call Circle you address each
one of the
elements in their various directions and
you ask them to join you in your Sacred
Space come to me
now I am
the spirits all agree Arendelle deserves
to stand with you you did what was right
for everyone did you find the fifth
Spirit you are the fifth Spirit you are
the bridge well actually a bridge has
two sides and mother had two daughters
we did this
together and we'll continue to do this
together listen how they talk about the
kingdom falling and the world didn't
fall and Elsa didn't die and then she
says I'm the bridge the fifth spirit in
witchcraft that fifth spirit is
literally Satan so describing that
there's Spirits all around you and that
you should listen to them is a theme
that we're starting to see in all of
these
Productions I can hear you and when that
voice starts to whisper
Mo listen it calls me all around you are
spirits child they will guide you I hear
the wind
[Music]
the Bible says in Revelation
18:23 that the end of the world will
deal with a deception that uses sorcery
so paying attention to all these stories
that have these elements and the magic
sorcery witchcraft these are literally
numbing your mind to these things and we
know that these are going to be used in
the end of time so don't let these
movies Place seeds into you or your
child's mind that witchcraft is okay to
play with that even though the Bible
tells us not to get involved in these
things that nothing big or no big
consequence is going to come out of this
let's steer clear of these kind of
things that are planting messages in
your mind that are different than what
God wants for us in our lives
[Music]